[Música]
Reino Unido acordó pagarle a Francia 577
millones de dólares en tres años para
tratar de detener a los migrantes que
viajan en pequeñas embarcaciones a
través del Canal de la Mancha el acuerdo
que podría ser el final de las disputas
que llegaron con el brexit no pasó
indemne a la crítica pues una vez más en
Londres Se busca enviar el problema de
los migrantes a terceros países este
tema lo vamos a analizar con Ana
González ella es abogada y además es su
jefa de inmigración de Wilson solicitors
London Ana gracias por estar en directo
a América
Hola buenos días la decisión fue parte
de una cumbre en la que vimos que los
dos mandatarios se esforzaron por
reconstruir los lazos después de la
salida del Reino Unido de la Unión
Europea se puede decir que es una pago
por esta reconciliación
lo es desde luego que sí lo es este
gobierno está completamente Desesperado
con el tema de la inmigración
se niegan a dar opciones
para para la seguridad de la gente que
cruza el Canal de la Mancha y lo que
están haciendo Es simplemente malgastar
grandes sumas de dinero que en este
momento la economía británica no se
puede no se puede permitir para para
solventar un problema que de una forma
que es imposible de solventar bueno
justo sobre eso iba mi siguiente
pregunta y es si se puede poner en duda
este acuerdo cuando el Reino Unido no
vive de su mejor situación financiera
precisamente desatada por Pues todos los
efectos del brexit pero es que además
preocupa que este acuerdo guarda
similitudes con el que finalmente se
firmó anteriormente con Ruanda y
serviría Para apoyar esta nueva
legislación que es una que ha venido
impulsando para prohibir que quienes
lleguen en Los pequeños botes al país
puedan solicitar asilo efectivamente
Francia puede ayudar para impulsar esta
política al interceptar los botes y
según las redes de tráfico de migrantes
efectivamente nadie sabe los términos de
este acuerdo lo que sabemos es el dinero
que se va que se va que se le va a pagar
a Francia más o menos eso sí se ha
publicado lo que no sabemos son los
términos no sabemos solamente qué es lo
que van a hacer esto como usted ya
comentó hubo un pago previo el año
pasado para patrullar
la costa la costa de las zonas de duncar
que de la costa francesa para evitar
este tipo este tipo de embarcaciones Sin
embargo no ha funcionado los emigrantes
han llegado en números muchos más altos
mucho más mucho más altos O sea que no
el detergente no ha funcionado para nada
Entonces ahora no sabemos exactamente
qué es lo que quieren hacer posible se
rumorea que quieren hacer un centro de
acogida que siempre hemos gente como
nosotros abogados ongs siempre hemos
abogado por este tipo de
de política que sería una forma segura
para estos inmigrantes poder pedir asilo
antes de llegar a suelo británico y
jugarse la vida en el canal de la
bueno Ana estamos teniendo algunos
problemas de conexión espero me esté
escuchando y quisiera ir planteando mi
siguiente Pregunta mientras se
recuperamos el video y es que habría que
ver si eso cuestionable En definitiva
que tanto este gobierno como su gobierno
antecesor hayan hablado prácticamente de
estar exportando personas exportar el
problema de la migración ilegal a
terceros países
bien hemos perdido entonces la
comunicación con Ana pero pues
reiteramos nuestro tema después de la
polémica de Reino Unido acordando
pagarle a Francia de 577 millones de
dólares durante tres años para detener a
los migrantes que llegan al país y le
preguntaban a usted Le repito sobre esta
esta duda humanitaria o ética moral si
quiere que plantea el hecho de que Reino
Unido está impulsando una política para
expulsar a migrantes a terceros países
trasladar el problema de la migración
ilegal para que otros países sean los
que lidian con ella
sino todo lo contrario hasta cierto
punto si quieren exportar cierto tipo de
refugiados El mayor problema que tenemos
con esta política es que el gobierno
está diferenciando varias categorías de
refugiados
de la forma que ellos quieren y los que
no los que llegan a la forma del Reino
Unido las vías legales Que tanto se
debaten por el gobierno y por otros
medios las vías legales solo están al
alcance de un cierto una cierta
categoría de personas son los que no
necesitan visados para venir a Reino
Unido por cualquier tipo de razón los
ucranianos gente de Hong Kong y
varias categorías de refugiados el resto
no pueden venir de forma legal hay que
darse cuenta el Reino Unido es una isla
no tenemos fronteras terrestres no puede
acercarse llegar uno a la frontera y
pedir asilo es imposible la única forma
de pedir asilo es presencialmente
reunido y para ello hay que no tienen
acceso a vías leales tienen que hacerlo
es el problema bueno y el tema de la
exportación
el problema de la exportación que usted
hable el controvertido plan de Ruanda
eso es un plan de Ruanda eso es un plan
un plan Espeluznante espantoso ilegal
pero aparte todo esto Solo acoge a 200
personas Eso es lo que la gente no se da
cuenta O sea que aunque fuera
legal y viable no no cogería el número
de refugiados que están llegando Reino
Unido en este momento
ya lo que le quería preguntar y ya esta
sería mi última pregunta porque nos
quedamos sin tiempo rápidamente es esto
es polémico no Mientras que Reino Unido
no permite el ingreso de personas que
buscan asilo y al final pues hacerse una
vida en Europa el país está sufriendo
por falta de personal para hacer
trabajos de la vida diaria Entonces no
habría posibilidad de encontrar un
acuerdo más humanitario más
conciliatorio que permitiera dar un
hogar digno a las personas que lo
necesitan y al mismo tiempo solucionar
un gravísimo problema que tiene el Reino
Unido en este momento
por supuesto Lo que pasa que el problema
es que no hay no hay voluntad política
por parte del gobierno para hacerlo lo
que el gobierno está haciendo este
gobierno está completamente desesperado
la economía está estancada tenemos el
problema de inmigración hay problemas
con la sanidad pública hay todo tipo de
cosas hemos estado muy afectados no solo
también por covid como todo el mundo de
eso no se ha liberado nadie y lo que
pasa es que están tomando el camino
populista que ha tomado Trump y que han
tomado muchos otros para para intentar
hacerlas el poder con cara a la elección
del año que viene lo que yo creo que va
a ser bastante difícil para ellos esa es
la razón la razón por la cual no se está
liberalizando la inmigración Aunque
necesitemos necesitemos mucho personal
en este momento
pues mire Ana Yo le agradezco mucho por
sus impresiones y por las opiniones que
nos entrega Le deseo que tenga un feliz
día y vamos a continuar con el
cubrimiento de esta y otras noticias
gracias a ustedes y a nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros ya
volvemos con titulares
[Música]